[Music]
[Applause]
my lord
[Music]
wipe the little savage you are I fear
you are not much fun marksman though the
crude hands of a farmer but enough to
inning plows than muskets
[Music]
but a cruel rendering apparently the
rebels will pay more for my services
than his majesty
[Music]
Dylan that's my dueling pistols custom
it with your satisfaction the Lord
[Music]
see that
for taller are you prepared to receive
this young man smart young man
I promise fine
[Music]
State
thanks for watching you guys wanna see
what kind of challenges we face and
trying to bring a video game to life in
the real world chicken the
behind-the-scenes video a lot of cool
stuff in there yeah if you want to see
where we got a lot of the inspiration
from shake up the trailer for Assassin's
Creed 3 looks can't wait
anyways if you haven't yet follow us on
Twitter or like us on Facebook cuz it's
a great way for us to stay connected
with you
and for you guys to talk to us alright
guys yeah have fun